that's the thing i feel a lot of people
uh a lot of people
maybe have you know maybe have different
different conditions or different mental
conditions that they've just never
really thought about because like me
maybe you've found a way to cope with it
day to day you know because like me
maybe you thought that hey maybe
everyone's like this and you've just
found a way to live normally because
uh because you've grown up uh you've
grown up in an environment where you
just need to like just get on with it
basically and a lot of a lot of the
times like not every mental condition is
just like on the extreme end sometimes
it's like really really subtle yeah but
if you've ever like had a thought that
maybe maybe i do have this or maybe i do
have that i think it might be worth just
talking to someone not like not to like
have like a life-changing aha moment but
just learning more about yourself i feel
like is the most valuable thing that
someone someone can do and uh doesn't
mean that doesn't mean that there's
necessarily anything wrong with you you
know i think people more people would
probably go if it was like easier to get
seen yeah yeah definitely most places
right it's like yeah yeah yeah gotta be
either rich or have a lot of time on
your hands yeah or both yeah both to get
anything done health care wise or mental
health wise i don't know i know in the
uk it's not too great i know they're
like yeah i'm trying to get better at it
but i know it's not adequate yeah in the
uk it's like the waiting list is like
[ __ ] [ __ ]
like huge yeah
yeah because um yeah because i feel like
the biggest problem especially
like everywhere but america i can see
it's like access to mental health care
is
it's difficult to sell especially in
asia in japan dude it's like oh my god
half the time it's just like
non-existent yeah my mental health in
japan is the izakaya there is no
there is no
it's like go to the pub yeah drink a
beer don't think about it
i know why you're sad it's because
you're not drunk right now go to an
izakaya have a couple of beers you'll be
all right and then it's just no i was
like i i was walking home and i saw a
guy just like on the floor he was crying
in in tokyo and i was like why is like
no one no one helping him hmm
like loads of people just walking past
him like why is no one saying like hey
are you okay this is so weird to me
people are just like man i don't wanna
don't wanna get involved yeah yeah they
don't they don't that's the thing that's
so [ __ ] sad they see because in a
again collectivist society they see one
you know uh cog that's out of the system
and they're like well that's not our
problem we're just gonna keep the call
we're just gonna keep the system moving
yeah the uk isn't great but i think at
least where i was from if someone was
like crying in the street like everyone
would be like you okay oh yeah yeah yeah
i think i'd say most english-speaking
countries though definitely be at least
a couple of people be like hey yeah
you're right dude what's up yeah kind of
at least like someone checking on them
yeah exactly and you know not to say
that japan isn't you know the [ __ ]
cruel mistress of the world in that
sense right like there's definitely
people i've seen people you know go up
to strangers yeah i wanted to help but i
was like i don't
want this to be an awkward
language-barrier situation where you
actually need help and i i'm just like
oh hi you know yeah i thought i felt so
sad about that i couldn't do anything to
help you
because i was like i don't
i don't know just imagining what
situations he could be going through
maybe so [ __ ] sad i was like what if
what if his parents like to tell he
couldn't go home or something yeah i was
like
yeah man yeah i just wanted to add an
addendum to what i said uh if you do
like i i think a big issue and nowadays
as well as like there's a lot of
self-diagnosis yeah yeah like i
especially i've seen it on tick-tock
doctors like like they're like i've read
one google ass call i am like i you know
i'm like i got this adhd or i'm like
well it's almost like the yeah what's
the word the like collection of uh
people you know people kind of say what
you will but online they kind of see it
as like a badge of honor yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah people do that i'm
if i have xx thing and i have it in my
bio i'm like i'm part of your brownie
points
or you're like immune to like yeah
sometimes like being an [ __ ] or
something right yeah yeah like it's just
like it's i don't know i i
it sucks because you don't want to be
like man people are faking it but it's
like there are people faking it they
don't see it as like a badge of honor in
a way yeah yeah
and even and you know even if you're
proud about it you can be proud about it
and be open about it yeah yeah exactly
is it like don't be a dick about it yeah
self-diagnosing so that you can then go
and brag about it online he's like what
the [ __ ] yeah yeah
but people actually have to deal with
this [ __ ] yeah yeah i know right
actually
and then that whole argument comes into
like well we couldn't afford to go to a
doctor and get actual diagnosis and it's
like yeah but you probably still should
never diagnose i don't think anyone ever
would recommend you self-diagnose no no
no
completely wrong especially with
something as delicate and as complicated
as mental health
like like i said the mind is a
complicated thing and people do weird
[ __ ] a lot of the times and uh you can
you can never know unless you really see
like an expert you know that's then it
also sucks as well because then you see
an expert maybe the expert was a [ __ ] of
this job or something you know so
there's always this like [ __ ]
minefield yeah yeah like like counter
arguments have have you ever like had a
bad experience with like a doctor or
anything like that
yeah i've had doctors where i'm like yo
this thing is actually like [ __ ]
hurting me and then he's like oh no it's
good
and i'll be like
i don't know i'm like some bad
pain's like no you're good
and then i got another doctor he's like
oh holy [ __ ] man you gotta this is like
you gotta sort this out i've had a lot
of instances where i go to like a local
doctor like a local gm and they'll be
like i'll refer you to a bigger hospital
yeah after looking at it for like two
seconds and then you go to the bigger
hospital and they're like oh here's some
drugs you can get anywhere i'm like
why did the guy at the local gm not do
that instead of [ __ ] wasting my time
taking me to another bigger hospital
that's way further away yeah to do the
exact same job that he could have done
yeah you know
probably the only one i've had yeah
because especially me like right now i'm
like i think my biggest 30s like health
thing that i've that i've found so much
is like my jaw my jaw issue and so i've
been like trying to get someone i've
been trying to find an expert to help me
sort it out so you know i go to
i go to the dentist to try and like try
and find out what's wrong with my jaw
right
and so
like i mean i remember the first time
i've tried to get it sorted out was uh i
remember when i went to like several
dentists in the uk
and uh one of them said oh do you still
have your wisdom teeth and they were
like and i was like yeah i still have my
wisdom teeth but like they're not like
the spacing in it isn't like it isn't
bad or anything it's not like hurting me
or anything like that and they're like
yeah we recommend you get that uh we
recommend you get that taken out i was
like okay do i that's a that's a big
commitment you know yeah because you
know at the time i was still a youtuber
um so you know
you can't you can't you can't talk you
can't talk so i like i wanted to make
sure that i needed to go through this
procedure uh so i went to a second
dentist for a second opinion and he was
like no definitely don't take your
wisdom teeth out that's not the issue um
here have this mouth guard and i was
like okay he gave me the mouth like
improved it a little bit by like the
problem still persisted sorry uh he i
went back to him and he's like
yeah honestly uh maybe you need uh
braces or something uh that's gonna cost
like thirty thousand pounds or something
i was like okay let's get let's uh if
unless let's be sure i need to go
through this and i get so like at this
point i'd move to japan yeah right and
then come to come to japan
go do the same thing go to the dentist
and they were like
you don't need to take your wisdom teeth
out but maybe just take the top wisdom
teeth out i'm just like i'm getting like
a dip like every dentist i've gone
through so far has given me a different
opinion about what needs to be done so
i'm like who do i listen to you know
another one
you only need to remove half your wisdom
teeth just like the top half just like
shave it off a little bit yeah yeah yeah
just shave the top off you'll be all
right yeah i'm just like
it's it's so like i i want to get it
fixed but i just it's it's scary because
whatever i go through it's a big
commitment obviously in time and cost
and it's my body i want to make sure
it's done right um but at the same time
everyone everyone i say everyone i meet
is telling me different things so i have
i have no [ __ ] clue who to listen to
basically i got like tonsil i just like
i used to get like every year right and
they were like just remove your tonsils
and i was like oh i don't really want it
because they said they say there's a
chance it can like affect your voice
yeah yeah and i was like i'd rather just
be sick once a year and now yeah like a
lot of pain well you haven't had it in a
while though right no luckily i haven't
had it in a while i don't think i've had
it in japan yeah right yeah i used to
get like every year right yeah pain in
the ass i still want my voice to change
so i was like i like my voice right now
yeah it's kind of important to my job
yeah yeah what if i change it although
they say like you have a chance that the
voice will change but it's not like
you're going to be like hey guys what's
happening no i know i'm just like i have
learned how to
use my voice yeah
for like voice acting
like
you're going to like re-learn it i don't
know how it would feel i i don't
they they just told me there's a chance
it could change slightly yeah like
for me it's just not worth it i was like
i'll just be sick every now and then
yeah
i'll take the sickness like i'll just be
sick slightest isn't real
it's not an illness
it's a mindset
your like throat closes up so much it
feels like it's like you know there's
like [ __ ] squishy toys where you put
your finger in it yeah that's how i
imagine your throat looks like yeah it's
horrible it's so bright that sounds
gross yeah no it's not that bad it's
just your voice how do you get it you
just like it's like it's like a virus
you pick up or yeah i believe it's a
virus it's like an infection on your
tonsil oh okay right it might be viral
or kissing
or something i don't know
it's just just [ __ ] too many dicks
now that i'm a georgia fan i've got to
be careful
you can't be going on anything
yeah don't want to pick up tunnel
from my next blog
generally i just avoid going to the
hospital or clinic at all costs i'm like
yeah yeah i mean i've said this before i
just don't want to go yeah i don't know
i'll just be like dead before i go
that's just like really severe i'm in
like a lot of pain yeah